[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa de radio
Francia internacional en colaboración
con la televisión France 24 en español
en la que damos siempre es la palabra
agente del mundo de la política de las
artes de las ciencias de la cultura los
deportes y sobre todo de la sociedad
civil el gobierno de Colombia y la
guerrilla de las FARC las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de Colombia
firmaron un acuerdo de paz en el 2016
con el propósito de poner fin al
conflicto militar armado que agitaba ese
país desde 1960 seis años después y
aunque formalmente los combates se Han
detenido la violencia sigue afectando a
decenas de miles de colombianos es el
caso de la comunidad de paz de San José
de la apartadó ubicada en el noroeste de
Colombia cerca de la frontera con Panamá
región que por sus recursos naturales
semeja a un paraíso sobre tierra San
José del apartador del apartado Perdón
es objeto de saqueo de sus recursos y
sus habitantes blanco de asesinatos de
secuestros y depresión y extorsión de
diversos agentes una delegación de la
comunidad de San José del apartado nos
acompaña hoy en esta escala en París
Germán Graciano ustedes representante
legal de dicha comunidad desde el 2013
es la más alta autoridad de esa
comunidad bienvenido escala en París
Gracias y Rubí ustedes también miembro
de la comunidad de San José de apartadó
fue miembro del Consejo interno la más
alta autoridad de dicha comunidad entre
el 2013 y el 2018 bienvenida escala en
París
bienvenidos ambos
Germán yo quisiera hacer una primera
pregunta por qué eligieron el nombre de
comunidad de paz de San José del
apartado
Gracias nuevamente creo que el nombre
lo eligen especialmente la gente que
fundó la comunidad que hoy muchos de
ellos no están
porque
era Era como una reflexión en torno a
vivir todos en Solidaridad y
especialmente en comunidad entonces creo
que fue Generalmente el nombre que que
se le da porque nos conformamos como
comunidad no como asociación como juntas
sino como comunidad hermana solidaria
rubia Arteaga Cuál es el objetivo de
esta misión de esta delegación qué es lo
que están haciendo durante esta gira sé
que han visitado varios países
estudiando en el Reino Unido en España
en Italia en Alemania en Suiza entre
otros Cuál es el propósito de este viaje
el propósito general es dar a conocer la
situación que hay en las regiones la
preocupación que tenemos la comunidad en
tema de tierras en crecimiento
paramilitar que hay en la zona digamos
el objetivo es dar a conocer todos esta
situación actual que se está viviendo en
la comunidad
Germán ustedes funcionan a un doble
principio a saber que es que no aceptan
en sus tierras ningún actor armado y al
mismo tiempo no dialogan con ningún
actor armado porque este objetivo que
también les ha causado evidentemente
bastante bastantes problemas en términos
de asesinatos secuestros y demás
porque fue un descubrimiento pues del
campesinado de esa región de San José
apartado de cómo
todo lo que lo que se vivías
estéticamente la violaciones y las
masacres y los asesinatos eran enfocado
a un señalamiento de ser colaborador de
cualquiera de los actores por cualquiera
de los actores señalaban al campesinado
y pues es como esa forma de de
Buscar
alejarnos de del conflicto de del
señalamiento buscando una solución
pacífica neutral de no colaborar con
ninguno de los actores armados para ver
si obteníamos el respeto a la vida y a
la tierra la región de la apartadó es
una región muy rica decíamos se parece a
una especie de paraíso sobre la Tierra
posee minerales está cerca del Atlántico
del Pacífico decíamos cerca de la
frontera de Panamá y al mismo tiempo uno
de los puntos nodales del acuerdo de paz
del 2016 que atraviesa todavía hoy a
Colombia es la restitución de tierras
que nos puede decir a este respecto cómo
les afecta a ustedes esto Bueno yo creo
que la comunidad el tema de la
restitución de tierras afecta bastante
porque digamos que no sea
no se ha tomado de verdad como se se
planteó Y en vez de ayudar a las
comunidades a los a los campesinos lo
que hace es afectarlos porque eso hace
que el tema de restitución de tierras se
se voltee más como a dársela a las
empresas o a los altos terratenientes y
y a los campesinos y a las comunidades
no se les está a la comunidad en general
no se le está reconocimiento
reconocí reconociendo el el territorio
que ella tiene durante estos 25 años de
lucha Y entonces ahorita la comunidad le
afecta bastante este tema de la
restitución de tierra creo que nos está
haciendo debidamente cómo se planteó en
en estos acuerdos de paz cuando ustedes
hablan de agresiones dicen de actores se
refieren a actores del estado A grupos
paramilitares a grupos de la guerrilla
de las ejército popular
Cuáles ejemplos Me puede usted dar
concretamente uno o dos ejemplos de lo
que han sufrido ustedes como comunidad
yo quiero señalarle a nuestro público
165 personas de la comunidad de San José
del apartado han sido asesinadas en
estos 25 años me puede dar unos ejemplos
hoy quiero que en la región el
paramilitarismo ha sido bastante
digamos
aterrorizante y digamos la mayoría de
los crímenes y violación a nuestros
derechos ha sido por parte del
paramilitarismo junto con la brigada 17
y 180% de nuestros asesinatos de todo
esto ha sido también fue en su época la
guerrilla Entonces yo creo que estos
tres sectores son los que han ocasionado
el daño más grande a la comunidad es un
daño tan grande que se pone ustedes que
por ejemplo en el caso de Germán 13
miembros de su familia han sido
asesinados su padre sus hermanos sus
sobrinos en el caso de Rubí su tío fue
asesinado cuando él era el principal
dirigente de la comunidad de San José
del apartado y son crímenes Germán que
siguen en la impunidad total
Sí
para la comunidad y para el país a nivel
internacional pues son crímenes que son
crímenes de lesa humanidad ha tenido una
responsabilidad durante estos 25 años
especialmente
la brigada 17 pues y el gobierno
colombiano es del alto presidente de Los
Altos presidentes de turno Perdón 17 es
el ejército 17 es el ejército la séptima
brigada de carepa cerca al municipio de
apartadó es una de las responsables de
por digamos ya investigada y señalada
por la masacre del 21 de febrero del
2005 donde Asesinan a Luis Eduardo
guerra con su familia
esta comunidad de San José del apartado
sabemos ha cambiado ya el gobierno en
Colombia ha entrado en contacto Germán
con el nuevo gobierno con el gobierno
que encabeza el presidente Petro algunos
de los ministros del actual gobierno
estuvieron en su momento dado vinculados
a luchas sociales en defensa de la
tierra del medio ambiente esto ha
cambiado algo para ustedes para nosotros
en general las comunidades y la
comunidad de paz de San José apartadó
hay muchas expectativas en este cambio
de gobierno pero para nosotros no ha
cambiado nada porque hace ocho días fue
asesinado un joven de 18 años en el
casco urbano de San José apartado donde
está la policía y los militares y es así
que no hubo realmente Una
no ha habido realmente un acto que que
es ese la violencia del control
paramilitar en San José de apartado
viendo el sitio de internet de la gente
de San José del apartado yo aprendo que
están solo en el mes de septiembre
vivieron ustedes ocho agresiones Rubí
que tendría que hacer qué demandan
ustedes al gobierno del presidente Petro
para cambiar para modificar
cualitativamente esta situación de
violencia que viven Regularmente
yo creo que más que todo es como que se
Centre en mirar las situaciones que hay
en las regiones Son regiones aisladas es
verdad Entonces creo que el gobierno
siempre ha mantenido muy aislado todas
estas regiones estas comunidades yo creo
que algo que se debe enfocar es a estar
más pendiente de de estas agresiones que
sean en las regiones en las comunidades
en los procesos
Porque no solo en la comunidad en
Colombia se dan muchos muchas
violaciones de derechos y creo que el
estado nunca está presente viendo desde
cerca desde las regiones Yo pienso que
uno de sus trabajos es enfocarse en
revisar región por región Cuál es la
situación de cada lugar y ahí sí creo
que podrían hacer algo porque si no esto
en las regiones crece mucho el
paramilitarismo las incidencias todo ese
tipo de de grupos armados que que al
final son los que terminan
como gobernando o dominando las regiones
entonces creo que el enfoque de los del
presidente la tarea es revisar más
detalladamente qué pasa en las regiones
realmente
Germán decíamos al inicio de esta escala
en París Ustedes han visitado una serie
de países en Europa que balance hacen
hasta ahora de lo que ha llevado como gi
Sí para para la comunidad en general el
nombre hablamos el nombre de la
comunidad de paz San José apartado creo
que después de la pandemia de todo está
digamos cerramiento que hubo a nivel
mundial Pues creo que la comunidad se
sintió un poco sola en el en el tema
digamos de acompañamiento internacional
de un Louis en ciencia política a nivel
internacional y es así que esta gira
vuelve a tener esas esas redes presentes
de apoyo
político en temas de defensa de derechos
humanos y especialmente en la
problemática del territorio actualmente
entonces muy productiva esta gira que
hemos hecho el nombre de la comunidad de
paz porque es volver a unirnos a ver la
situación actual que estamos viviendo
como comunidad de paz Rubí sabemos que
el gobierno de Colombia y europea tienen
firmado un acuerdo económico
y que el gobierno de Francia también
hace parte de la Unión Europea qué le
piden ustedes concretamente al gobierno
francés como piden que intervenga para
solidarizarse con ustedes para apoyarles
qué podría ser el gobierno francés yo
creo que de uno de los digamos de
nuestra idea es que que se enfoquen más
en revisar todo el tema de los derechos
humanos y que realmente se haga un
cumplimiento de ellos y que digamos que
desde acá desde Francia se revise
Realmente si estos proyectos y estos
acuerdos están cumpliendo Y si está
haciendo de verdad a servicio de todo el
pueblo o solo de algunos entonces creo
que en general es que estén muy
pendiente de que los derechos y los
acuerdos que se que hay se cumplan y se
respete realmente la vida y no solo del
ser humano sino del territorio la tierra
que es como la vida igual de todo ser
al final de este escala en París no me
quedo haciendo agradecerle a Germán
Graciano representante legal de la
comunidad de paz de San José del
apartado su presencia Muchas gracias
Germán por habernos acompañado y
Judith Arteaga Rubí Muchísimas gracias
por habernos acompañado en este escala
en París
a ustedes les damos una nueva cita aquí
la próxima semana en otra escala en
París
[Música]